what's it like when you do solo work do
your brothers immediately give you
feedback or is it do they just going to
let you get on
it's just so great not to be around them
oh stop it
uh yeah they give me feedback probably
you know
one of if not the first people that i go
to
uh for feedback because you know they're
they're
trusted advisors as well as well as
friends and and also bandmates
um and you know just so happy i don't
split the money three ways yeah
incredible [ __ ]
and i know you guys talk a lot but
wasn't there a thing where you changed
your number oh yeah which one was
problems
yeah so i i guess i changed my number a
couple years back and it was
attached to my old icloud account so
someone got my number and became really
furious i would imagine
if a bunch of people kept hitting them
saying hey nick you know what's up and
he's like
who is this you know i'm looking for
nick jonas that the person would
start to get frustrated and they did so
much to the point where they were going
to call the cops and there was a whole
situation yeah because i think we've got
the picture so this is when your album
came out
and people were sending lots of
congratulations and you go stop texting
this number
it still comes up as you yeah the funny
part is
this guy zach is one of the producers of
the album um
so he he was probably shocked when i
wrote this
[Laughter]
i guess i won't be working with him
again
i feel bad for whoever that was and i
think maybe now because
i've spoken about this one at a time
they must know that it actually was my
old number
yeah i'd start going i'd respond to it
like
yeah i can come to that event don't
worry
not a problem yeah i'll clear some space
in my diary
just send the money there
[Music]